AFOREMENTIONED MINNESOTA
VICTORY, LEON DRAISAITL WINNING
THE FACE-OFF ANDND SUCCESSFUL OM
INJURY.
THAT PUCK INTO THE SLOT AND A
QUOT, SCORES!
ERIKSSON EK MAKING IT 2-0, A
MINNESOTA WILD POWER-PLAY GOAL E
WITH THE STICK, MAKING A NICE
MOVE RIGHT THERE.
>> Louie: SOME MISTAKES HERE
COSTINGY GO RIGHT TO
WORK.
JAYY BY MERYL
AND OF GAMES
AGO, WE'LL KEEP A EYE RIGHT
THERE.
DLE THAT PASS, CLEANLY. HANDLE,S
PICKING UP CONFIDENCE, WHO ARE K
YOU DOWN INTO THE NET, THIYEAR.
>> Jack: THIS THE
FIRSTT, THE OILERS
HAVE NOT HAD ANYTHING IN THE
THE
AND THAT PUCK ON
FINISHING THOSE SCRUMS AND
FITTING TO HAVE TO
HOLD THE Z Z HOCKEY LEAGUAND NO,
McLEOD NOWAND HOW ABOUT A SHORTL
AND TALKING